Guten Morgen Linus. Ich habe gehört, der Chaos Computergip lässt sich versteckt hinten rum bezahlen.
Ja, wenn dann immer nur versteckt und hintenrum.
Logbuchnetzpolitik vom sechsundzwanzigsten März zweitausendneunzehn.
Ihr habt Mollintro gehört und ihr habt's wahrscheinlich auch in den Nachrichten verfolgt. Heute ist.
Ein trauriger Tag für Lokbuchnetzpolitik und ein trauriger Tag für das Internet.
Wenngleich vielleicht auch nicht das Ende des Internets so doch ein.
Herber Rückschlag für einen vernünftigen und freien Wissensaustausch und ein herber Rückschlag auch für diejenigen, die sich in den letzten.
Monaten und Jahren ähm für eine rationale Lösung.
Der Urheberrechtsreform engagiert haben, die sich als.
Bots und gekaufte äh bezeichnen lassen mussten. So jetzt auch der Chaos-Computerclub. Übrigens von Elec Empire, Elec Empire.
Empire.
Das Schöne ist, dass du nicht der Erste bist, der fragt. Ähm sag dir, Athary Teenager etwas.
Ich weiß, wir sind Atari ist ähm aber das ist es auch schon.
Das ist eine ähm eine äh Band, die doch tatsächlich vor ähm ja.
Jetzt müsste ich auch gucken, aber sofort zwanzig Jahren ungefähr schon durchaus äh sinnstiftend war für ein äh für eine Generation an äh wahrscheinlich äh.
Ja ich also ich weiß nicht wie man, ich ich kann Musik schlecht beschreiben, aber sehr, der Name sagt schon sehr, der der Name passt sehr gut zu der Musik, ne? Ähm.
Halt irgendwie so Generationen, Computer, ähm Punkrock, Style, Musik ähm in einigen ähm.
Doch denke ich ein ein sehr begnadeter Musiker.
Der insbesondere auch im im Bereich des Kraftcomputerclubs durchaus viele viele Fans und Anhänger hat und übrigens auch beim äh CCC-Kongress.
Mal die Keynote gehalten hat, äh die aber jetzt nicht äh historisch besonders eingegangen ist, als als eine.
Als eine besonders herausragende, herausragende Keynote. Ich hab keine Ahnung, so 'n Rockstar-Leben ist ja durchaus mit äh verschiedenen
Bewusstseinserweiternde Substanzen, manchmal verbunden. Ich weiß nicht, welcher, welche Tube Lack das war, ähm ziehe es sich da reingezogen hat, aber selbst der der Link, den er dazu hatte, das war nämlich der Link, den du äh äh den, den wir letztes Mal schon besprochen hatten. Thomas mit den
äh dass Etri ja jetzt hier die Leute bezahlt und so. Da steht eigentlich auch spezifisch drin, dass der Chaoscomputerclub von Mitgliedsbeiträgen getragen ist.
Ich sehe da auch in der Tabelle nirgendwo, dass irgendjemand vorne rum oder hinten rum beim Chaos-Computerclub von irgendjemandem Geld genommen hätte.
Um sich gegen Uploadfilter zu engagieren.
Ah, ich finde das ja schön, das heißt, ihr seid jetzt auch in den Club aufgenommen worden, dass ihr euch zu einem äh Urheberrechtsthema äußert und den, wie zu erwartenden,
ausgesetzt seid, die absolut jeder Grundlage entbehren, aber euch überhaupt die, das Mandat absprechen, wieso er überhaupt den Mund aufmacht, weil das ist uns auch hier passiert. Ähm.
Ich habe äh
egal ob jetzt irgendwie Überwachungsgesetze und jedenfalls mit Innenministerin oder äh deutsche Telekom äh noch nie sowas Heftiges erlebt, wie es halt für die Pletschkampagne machen, was so an Feindungen und irgendwelche
guten Verschwörungstheorien über uns und unsere Finanzen betrifft. Also sobald du dich in dem Thema äußerst, egal wer du bist, egal was du vorher gemacht hast, ähm.
Einfach das, was auch immer jetzt gerade die simple Antwort ist, um sich eben nicht mit den eigentlichen Argumenten auseinanderzusetzen.
Ich glaube, du kannst ehrlich gesagt nur nur eine Sache machen, mit der du mir, mit der du dir noch mehr Feine machst und das ist irgendwie ertrinkende Menschen im Mittelmeer retten.
Das ist das ist die einzige Sache, mit der du dir noch mehr Feinde machst, als dich ähm im Urheberrecht äh für für kleine
Kulturschaffende einzusetzen und gegen eine Stärkung äh von Google und YouTube. Und das leider gezwungen, das mit Argumenten zu tun, die nicht ganz so so unterkomplex sind
wie? Ja. Äh was ja ungefähr das Kernargument der Urheberrechtslobby äh war.
Ja, weil wir haben verloren. Ähm die eine kritische Abstimmung, über die wir auch in der letzten Folge schon gesprochen haben, nämlich darüber,
Änderungsanträge überhaupt zugelassen werden. Wir haben die Haarscharf verloren. Da haben uns fünf
gefehlt und äh dann am Ende die gesamte Richtlinie inklusive Artikel elf und dreizehn. Äh ich glaube, es waren so um die äh siebenundvierzig Stimmen, ähm die.
Gegen uns waren für die Annahme der Richtlinie und das ist natürlich ein herber Verlust
das das bringt doch irgendwie viele Fragen mit, was man noch hätte tun können. Ich glaube, wir haben fast alles getan, aber halt nicht in allen Ländern
Und ähm ja, dass das äh
lässt uns jetzt auch irgendwie mal Fragen zurück. Es ist auf jeden Fall die Zeit für Manöverkritik, für den Postmortem. Einerseits der Pletschkampagne, aber auch so der gesamten netzpolitischen ähm Community
Ja
Und in einer Ultraschall-Expedition an die Grenzen des Audiorotings haben wir jetzt nicht nur Wien in der Leitung, sondern auch Straßburg. Herzlich willkommen Julia.
Julia, woran hat es gelegen?
Oh je, also ich meine äh wir wussten ja vorher nicht so richtig, ob wir super optimistisch sein sollen oder ob wir schon längst verloren haben. Am Ende war es genauso wie ich
prognostiziert habe, es war extremst knapp. Also wir haben die Abstimmung, ob äh Änderungsanträge zugelassen werden und damit irgendwie die Streichung von den Upload-Filtern überhaupt abgestimmt wird. Da haben wir.
Mit fünf Stimmen Unterschied verloren.
Und äh letzten Endes, also wenn man weiß, wie jeder abgestimmt hat, kann man sich immer noch Gedanken machen, ob man nicht den ein oder anderen noch hätte, ähm.
Überzeugen können, aber ich glaub es war schon.
Eine Leistung überhaupt, wenn die drei großen Fraktionen irgendwie EVP, Sozialdemokraten und Liberale allesamt nöhnen.
Positive Wahlempfehlung auf ihrem Zettel stehen haben überhaupt irgendwie fast 'ne Mehrheit dagegen zu organisieren aber es hat halt leider nicht ganz gereicht und.
Ich glaube, es hat auch viel so in der Parlamentsmaschinerie äh dagegen gearbeitet, dass wir das Ganze nochmal irgendwie aufmachen können.
Das die erste Abstimmung war ja, ob man überhaupt getrennt über die ähm über die ähm Artikel abstimmt und die wurde um fünf Stimmen verloren. Habe ich das richtig gesehen?
Das ist richtig und das ist ehrlich gesagt auch ziemlich fischi abgelaufen, weil ähm.
Also den Vorsitz über die Abstimmung hatte der Parlamentspräsident Tayani, der auch dafür bekannt ist, dass er irgendwie der Urheberrechtsstauby ziemlich nah steht
und der hat halt gesehen.
Also nachdem er quasi die Abstimmung eröffnet hatte, dass auch eine ganze Reihe von äh Christdemokraten für Änderungsanträge gestimmt haben. Und dann hat er die Abstimmung einfach
offen gelassen und hat gesagt, hm, offensichtlich sind sich nicht alle sicher, worüber wir gerade abstimmen, da herrscht Verwirrung und in der Zwischenzeit hat irgendwie Axel Voss noch wil.
Stikuliert und versucht Überzeugungen zu leisten, dass Leute dagegen stimmen. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob das irgendjemanden beeindruckt hat, aber irgendwie vom Verfahren her war das nicht so su
sauber. Und ja, also das heißt, unterm Strich hätten drei Leute, die mit Nein gestimmt haben, bei den Änderungsanträgen mit ja gestimmt
dann wär's eine Mehrheit gewesen, aber die haben wir leider verpasst.
Und dann war es ja auch noch so, dass drei schwedische Abgeordnete
äh ähm im Nachhinein jetzt auch schon gesagt haben, dass sie sich vertan haben. Also, dass sie eigentlich anders abstimmen wollten, aber ähm das in dem Moment falsch gemacht haben oder den falschen Knopf.
Haben, die können jetzt vielleicht sogar ihre Stimme noch korrigieren, aber das ändert nichts mehr am Endresultat.
Ja, also ich glaube, es waren nur zwei die Schwedendemokraten, aber da muss man ganz ehrlich sagen, also das ist ja auch so eine komische, rechte Partei, äh wenn die halt nicht kompetent genug sind, sich vorher zu überlegen, wie sie abstimmen wollen, das hieft einem dann hinterher auch nichts, wenn sie sagen, es tut ihnen furchtbar leid, dass sie auf den falschen Knopf gedrückt haben.
Du hast dann noch eine Rede gehalten, die gerade auch in den äh sozialen Medien etwas viral geht
weil du mehrfach mit Zwischenrufen unterbrochen wurdest, ist das ähm auch im EU-Parlament so üblich.
Ja, nicht wirklich. Also man sieht ja, dass äh
und ähm ich habe nicht so ganz verstanden, was das Anliegen von Herrn Kaspari war, da habe ich gesagt, also der hätte gesagt, äh Demonstranten wurden gekauft und dann hat er sich beschwert und mir ein Zitat vorgelesen, indem er sagt, Demonstranten wurden gekauft, also war etwas äh merkwürdig.
Ich habe dann noch.
Bin ich eigentlich nur durch Spiegel online drauf aufmerksam geworden, weil das die dieses Bild hatten ähm von der Abstimmung, da gibt's einen Abgeordneten mit Namen Frank Bogovic.
Der sogar so ein Pösterchen, so ein Poster mitgenommen hatte, so ein knallgelbes wo äh Rot Yes drauf stand und das ähm.
Stammt irgendwie aus etwas mir nehmen und noch nicht ganz so nachvollziehbarer Quelle, aber das ist irgendwie
Lobbyverband der Verwertungsrechteverwerter, die ihm da offenbar ein Plakat noch beim Treffen gegeben haben und der hat das mit in Parlament geschleppt. Ich weiß, dass das im Bundestag
Ähm, so glaube ich nicht unbedingt möglich wäre, zumindest hätte ich mit, wäre ich mit dem Plakat nicht auf die ähm auf die Zuschauertribüne gekommen. Ist das.
Üblich, dass man da bei euch mal irgendwie noch ein Schildchen mit reinnimmt, um zu zeigen, wie man drauf ist oder so.
Ja doch, also das wird bei den Abgeordneten schon toleriert. Also so sein Käsebrötchen darf man auf keinen Fall mit reinnehmen, aber äh die Ju.
Abgeordneten haben alle ihr Fähnchen auf ihren Tischen stehen und dass mal jemand irgendwie ein Poster dabei hat, ist auch nicht so ungewöhnlich. Ähm ich find's halt relativ bezeichnend, wenn jemand diese Copyright-Kampagne.
Im Plenum bewerben möchte, weil die halt doch relativ plump ist. Also wir haben von denen auch.
Heute Morgen nochmal Wurfsendungen in alle Abgeordnetenbüros bekommen, wo einfach nur draufsteht. Sag ja, sag ja, sag ja, sag ja, so ganz oft und ich weiß nicht, ob das so eine Art äh.
Weiß nicht, Neurolinguist, Shopogramirang sein soll oder so oder was die damit erreichen wollen, aber also ich finde solche Formen von Lobbyismus eher.
Abstoßend.
Du hast ja schon äh verkündet, dass du dich diesem Parlaments.
Tätigkeiten nicht mehr widmen möchtest. Ich glaube, du hast natürlich jetzt nach dem Engagement und vor allem
nach so vielen einfach mal ja kompetenten, besonnenen und informierten Auftritten natürlich eine relativ große Fanbasis, die du jetzt enttäuscht.
Ja, das tut mir furchtbar leid. Also äh ich habe äh glaube ich schon so zur Mitte des Mandats nach zwei Jahren oder so
beschlossen, dass ich nicht nochmal antrete. Also ich glaube, man kann im
Parlament extrem viel erreichen, aber es ist auch enorm frustrierend, weil ähm eigentlich der gesamte parlamentarische Betrieb irgendwie darauf ausgerichtet ist, dass da Leute furchtbar hart daran arbeiten, äh sich gegenseitig eins auszuwischen und ähm.
Letzten Endes äh ist selten auf Sachargumente ankommt. Also das sieht man ja auch ein bisschen in dieser Diskussion, die wir jetzt haben, hat die Bundesregierung womöglich den Upload-Filter nur zugestimmt wegen der North Stream Pipeline. Also wenn das tatsächlich so ist
dann ist ja in dem Moment jegliche sachliche Diskussion über das Für und wieder von Upload-Filtern mit äh der Bundesregierung regelrecht sinnlos, weil ja die Inhalte überhaupt nichts möchte im Abstimmverhalten der Region zu tun hatten
Und solche Dinge ähm.
Ja, sind, glaube ich, schwer zu ertragen, wenn man's einem um die Sache geht. Also ich interessiere mich halt wirklich fürs Urheberrecht und das tut im Parlament ansonsten kaum jemand und das mach
äh diese Diskussion sehr zermörbend.
Kannst du die Zusammenhänge mit der Pipeline da nochmal ganz kurz ähm erklären? Wir haben das
in der Sendung glaube ich nur kurz angesprochen, dass äh wie genau sind da die vermuteten Zusammenhänge und wie wie viele Bestätigungen oder wie viele Anhaltspunkte gibt's da tatsächlich für?
Also die Situation war die, es gab Beginn des Jahres
bei zwei EU-Gesetzgebungsverfahren gewissermaßen Stillstand im Rat, also dass man sich eben nicht auf eine gemeinsame Position einigen konnte.
Das eine war eben die Urheberrechtsreform, da kam das relativ überraschend im Januar, dass sich der Rat nicht auf eine.
Einigen konnte ähm eben auch, weil.
Deutschland dieses Startup Ausnahme oder Kleinunternehmen Ausnahme haben wollte von den Upload-Filtern und gesagt hat, also Unternehmen mit äh weniger als zwanzig Millionen Jahresumsatz sollen keine Upload-Filter einsetzen müssen.
Und genauso bei dem anderen ähm Dossier, mit dem ich mich jetzt weniger gut auskenne, das war die Energierichtlinie und dort gab es auch so einen Stillstand, also das eben eine Sperrminorität gab und äh es unklar war, wie sich das
äh wie sich der Rat zu einer Position durchringen kann
und wir haben dann vom französischen Kulturminister irgendwann erfahren, also der hat auf einer öffentlichen Veranstaltung gesagt.
Es habe ein Telefonat zwischen Macron und Merkel stattgefunden. Und nach diesem Telefonat waren plötzlich beide
Blockaden überwunden. Also es gab einen deutsch-französischen gemeinsamen Vorschlag zum Urheberrecht und es gab einen gemeinsamen deutsch-französischen Vorschlag zur Energierichtlinie. Und ähm.
Man munkelt seitdem in Brüssel, dass das womöglich was miteinander zu tun hat, äh Beweise habe ich dafür allerdings auch nicht. Also da hat wahrscheinlich die FAZ jetzt äh gestern in dem Artikel mehr rausgefunden.
Es gibt ja also solche Abwägungen, das klingt jetzt natürlich für Leute, die sich ähm.
Jetzt spezifisch mit dieser Oberrechtsreform auseinandergesetzt haben nach einem.
Nach einer sehr ungewöhnlichen, wenn nicht gar skandalösen Sache. Gleichzeitig ist das natürlich in der also zumindest im der Politik des Deutschen Bundestages.
Eigentlich etwas relativ häufiges, nicht unbedingt zwischen, also nicht zwischen Ländern. Ähm
aber relativ häufig gegen äh zwischen so etwas wie ähm Koalitionspartnern, ne? Das also irgendwie okay, wir wir die Linke braucht
um ihre Wählerinnen zu ähm zu begeistern, unbedingt folgendes Wahlversprechen, das eingelöst werden muss, die CDU muss um ihre Freunde in der Wirtschaft äh
zu befriedigen, folgendes Ergebnis bringen und dann wird halt irgendwie verhandelt, nicht dass CDU und Linke jemals
ernsthaft miteinander verhandelt hätten, deswegen habe ich jetzt hier mal ein fiktives Beispiel genommen. Wie ist das denn im EU-Parlament? Seid ihr von sowas in der Regel frei gewesen? Oder ist das da auch eher an der Tagesordnung, dass solche ja Sachfremden Abwägungen stattfinden.
Ja, also ich denke, dass das schon vorkommt und ich will das jetzt auch nicht äh
überdramatisieren. Also ich glaube der Unterschied ist einfach, wenn jetzt zum Beispiel eine in der Bundesregierung sowas gemacht wird, also dass die Regierung irgendwie ein Gesetzesvorhaben voranbringt, dass der SPD wichtig ist und ein anderes, dass der CDU wichtig ist
Das ist immer noch eine gemeinsame Öffentlichkeit gibt und das ist ein bisschen das, was jetzt fehlt bei der europäischen Diskussion, denn ähm.
Die Folge von der Einigung zum Urheberrecht war eben, dass in Deutschland zweihunderttausend Leute auf der Straße waren und in äh Frankreich niemand.
Und ähm auch die mediale Berichterstattung über äh die
Einigung in Deutschland und Frankreich war wirklich wie Tag und Nacht. Und ich glaube, das ist ein bisschen das Problem, also dass ähm letzten Endes äh.
Ist dann nicht die Möglichkeit gibt äh.
Ja quasi gemeinsam diese Debatte zu führen, ob ein solcher Kuhhandel denn akzeptabel ist oder nicht. Also wir können natürlich versuchen auch
äh Proteste in Frankreich zu loncieren, das sollte aber relativ schwierig werden
hier in Deutschland können wir dann eben nur auf die Bundesregierung einwirken und versuchen sie davon zu überzeugen, dass das kein sinnvoller Deal ist und äh irgendwie Druck auf die Regierung ausüben, dass sie im Rat vielleicht doch noch
gegen die Einigung zum Urheberrecht stimmt, denn ähm die endgültige Entscheidung ist ja noch nicht getroffen. Aber ich glaube, insofern ist halt so ein
Kuhhandel auf europäischer Ebene doch nochmal ein Stück problematischer, weil's halt nicht die gemeinsame Öffentlichkeit gibt, um das Ganze dann zu diskutieren.
Würdest du diese Begrenzung der Proteste, die er oder was heißt Begrenzung, aber diese ähm doch sehr starke Häufung der Proteste in Deutschland ähm wie erklärst du dir die.
Also ich glaube zunächst, dass es irgendwie so ein
'n Startschuss oder 'n Funken braucht damit so 'ne.
Protestwelle losgetreten werden kann und ich glaube, dass die Community in Deutschland einige Dinge sehr richtig gemacht hat, also äh ein bisschen Auslöser des Ganzen war, dass äh die
also die diese Online-Petition bei Change Dot Org äh gestartet haben halt äh zufällig aus Deutschland kommen und relativ präsent waren im Europaparlament von Anfang an.
Also die waren zum Beispiel mit einem Livestream auf YouTube zum Zeitpunkt der Trilogverhandlung und haben quasi vor der Tür gewartet
und haben über den Kanal von Herrn News Time die Leute interviewt, wie sie rausgekommen sind, wie das eigentlich also bei dem
groß medial aufbereiteten Verhandlungsereignis, also Brexit oder so machen das halt die klassischen Medien. Und das haben wir halt für die Urheberrechtsreform gemacht, also
da haben die dann äh Herrn Forst direkt nach der Verhandlung als einer der Ersten vor die Kamera gekriegt, ein paar Fragen gestellt und ähm.
Das hat einige Leute schon auf die Palme gebracht, weil man da halt doch gemerkt hat, dass von den Sachargumenten nicht so furchtbar viel angekommen ist. Und ich glaube auch, dass äh einfach dieser
unglaubliche Schlingerkurs der Bundesregierung auch dazu beigetragen hat. Und das sind natürlich alles
beides Dinge, die lassen sich jetzt nicht so einfach in anderen Ländern replizieren. Also man könnte zwar gucken, also was für äh ich weiß nicht ähm.
Communitys gibt es dort und kann man zu denen irgendwie anknüpfen, aber letzten Endes muss halt das Interesse und das Engagement aus der Community selber kommen, also auch äh die Leute,
diese Petition gestartet haben, das war halt ein ganz normaler Kleinunternehmer, der ein kleines Imagesport hat oder so
Leute die sich irgendwie über Discod und dergleichen zusammengefunden haben. Also das ist relativ organisch gewachsen und das kann man halt so nicht planen.
Ich frage mich, wenn ich da nochmal kurz nachhaken darf, also Axel Voss Deutscher, ja? Äh Julia Reder als kompetente ähm Opposition.
Punierende zu zu dem Ergebnis ähm die.
Inwiefern spielt das überhaupt eine Rolle, dass vielleicht Deutschland draufgeschaut hat, weil da im in gewisser Weise deutsche Pferde im Rennen waren? Hast du
Stellst du so so etwas auch fest? Also ich erinnere mich zum Beispiel ähm jetzt spontan nicht
daran, dass wir mal in Deutschland massiv gegen äh irgendwelche ähm Vorstöße ähm oder uns mit etwas auseinandergesetzt hätten,
wo primär im EU-Parlament zumindest von mir aus italienische oder spanische Parlamentarierin irgendwie beteiligt waren.
Ja, also vielleicht so ein bisschen bei der Netzneutralität, aber sicher nicht in dieser
Schärfe der Auseinandersetzung. Ähm also ja klar, ich glaube, da spielt eine Rolle. Ich hatte auch den Eindruck, als Günther Oettinger noch Digitalkommissar war, das war zwar furchtbar, aber da haben sich die Medien mehr für Digitalpolitik interessiert.
Als jetzt, wo das halt Maria Gabriel aus Bulgarien macht, die mehr oder weniger dasselbe erzählt, aber halt nicht ganz so platt wie äh Öttinger das tut.
Ja, es ist auf jeden Fall so, es hilft, wenn man ein Feindbild hat, wenn man um Politiker hat, der wie Öttinger wie Voss, äh.
Thema auf einer Art vertritt, wo klar ist, dass es auch ein Generationenkonflikt gibt
und dass das grundlegende Problem auch nicht verstanden wurde. Wenn man auf die Armen eingeht und dann einfach zeigt, okay, aber ich sehe das anders, weil das wäre ja ein ganz anderes Debat
Niveau als wir von Forster Ettinger ähm bisher
kannt haben. Ähm und ich meine, ich bin auch äh aus einem Land im deutschsprachigen Raum dadurch äh kann ich nicht für anderssprachige Länder sprechen, aber ich
auch innerhalb von Edri, ähm die die Besuchergruppe, über die wir bei der letzten Sendung schon gesprochen haben, die kam wirklich aus ähm ganz Europa. Also es gi
die Menschen, die das Thema kümmert. Ganz klar, es gibt auch die NGOs aus allen Ländern, äh die dran arbeiten
was halt wirklich fehlt, ist diese Netzpolitische Debatte und vielleicht ist das auch ein guter Moment, um mal wieder äh aufzuzeigen, dass dieser Podcast.
Auch der Cast Communication Kongress, also all das, was jetzt nicht im ersten Schritt gleich primär
ähm eine eine NGO ist die Kampagnenarbeit macht, aber etwas, das eine Community schafft, dass einen Diskursraum schafft, ähm einen großen Unterschied macht und ich finde, das kann man sogar auch ablesen an den.
Zahlen. Ähm, wir haben ja schon beim letzten Mal den Netzpolitical-Artikel verlinkt, wo wirklich aus allen Städten, wo am Samstag demonstriert wurde.
Versucht wurde wirklich die Zahlen zusammenzufassen und das sieht man recht klar, dass es einen Überhang äh in deutschen Städten gibt
und das ist dann außerhalb, auch wenn's in Athen irgendwie eine Demo gab, weil irgendwie, also nicht fünfundzwanzig Leute. Also ähm das, das ist aber auch etwas, wo ich glaube, das nehme ich auch mit.
So mein Resümee. Ähm äh wir müssen viel europäischer werden, in der politischen Community. Ähm wir haben zwar Idri, aber das ist ja.
Großteils nur Paulicy Work in den meisten anderen Ländern fehlt uns noch eine.
Tische Community, die die wirklich diese Themen atmet und solange wir das nicht haben, wird das Schlagzeit der
äh haben. Und das ist ein großes Problem. Also wir müssen es schaffen, dass äh das ganze Thema irgendwie äh woanders auch geatmet wird.
Ähm ja
dass äh bringt mich nämlich auch zu einem Punkt, so was hätten wir denn besser machen können. Also wir haben Wikipedia Blackout gehabt, was so wirklich so der die größte Kanone ist. Ähm
die ist eigentlich so aus der Internetrichtung gibt. Wir hatten Banner auf ähm Twitch, auf Redit, auf Pornhub und
am Ende des Tages ja, es hat dann fünf Votes gescheitert
Das sind sicherlich auch fünf Stimmen, die wir hätten kriegen können. Gleichzeitig mir fällt schwer zu sagen, was für konkret noch hätten tun können.
Also ich glaube letzten Endes hatten wir einfach zu wenig Zeit. Also es wurde halt äh versucht, diese Reform wirklich in eine.
Am Ende ähm fertig zu bekommen. Also normalerweise wäre die Abstimmung.
Normalen Zeiten für Übersetzung und so weiter eher im April zur Abstimmung gekommen und ich glaube die Zeit hätten wir auch gebraucht
weil ähm letzten Endes solche Dinge wie Wikipedia Blackout ähm von der Community
entschieden wurden, als die Proteste schon ziemlich groß waren oder als ich abgezeichnet hat, dass sie groß werden und dann war es vielleicht einfach schon ein bisschen zu spät. Also manche Blackouts waren eben auch erst gestern
Und dann hatte das nicht mehr genug Zeit, das ähm tatsächlich uns Leute mobilisiert, die sich dann an die Abgeordneten wenden
Ähm aber ich meine, das ist was, wo glaube ich die Community wenig für kann, weil natürlich äh
auf viele Arten versucht wurde, den Leuten zu sagen, also solange der Tridog noch lief, wurden Proteste abgetan mit der Aussage der Dex ist ja noch nicht fertig. Ihr wisst ja gar nicht, wie schlimm es wird und als er dann fertig war, war so gut wie keine Zeit, äh ihn tatsächlich zu diskutieren, sondern da wurde richtig auf die Tube gedrückt.
Jetzt also okay, das das ist dann auf wahrscheinlich die die öffentliche Wahrnehmung, also meine ist eher so ein bisschen gewesen, wir haben so lange über dieses Thema geredet und es ist
so oft ähm in in jetzt aber wirklich die wichtige Abstimmung und noch einmal und noch einmal, dass ja selbst ich über jetzt irgendwie dann doch längere Zeit, die wir das Thema behandelt haben. Ich weiß noch nicht mal, wann wir damit angefangen haben ähm der Prozess war in meinen Augen schon seine äh
ähm anderthalb zwei Jahre, die ja jetzt irgendwie zumindest uns hier beschäftigt hat und mich in einer in der Auseinandersetzung, aber gut, ich sehe, dass das wahrscheinlich in der breiten Öffentlichkeit
überhaupt nicht der Fall war.
Ja, also ähm ich glaube, was auch wichtig ist, ist irgendwie der der Faktor Sprache, also auch in Österreich waren ja die Demos wirklich nicht klein
und ich find's auch interessant, also dass ich jetzt sofort äh wieder Leute zu spontanen Demonstrationen zusammengefunden haben
weil glaube ich in Deutschland schon auch noch so ein bisschen
die Hoffnung da ist, dass vielleicht die Bundesregierung oder zumindest die SPD in der Bundesregierung jetzt sich doch nochmal quer stellt. Und ich würde da gerne nochmal.
Kurz drüber reden, also was ist überhaupt.
Also es ist extrem unwahrscheinlich oder kommt sehr selten vor, dass äh der Rat quasi ein Trilogergebnis nochmal ablehnt.
Dem das Parlament schon zugestimmt hat.
Gibt ein Präzedenzfall, also wo quasi ein äh eine Einigung bereits hergestellt war zwischen Parlament und Rat und dann.
In der Endabstimmung im Rat nochmal aufgemacht wurde und letzten Endes auch abgelehnt wurde, das waren die Softwarepatente ähm,
Das ist also möglich, allerdings ist natürlich die Frage, also wird äh die Bundesregierung, wird Kanzlerin Merkel, dass irgendwie ähm
beeindrucken, wenn da jetzt äh so viele Leute auf der Straße sind. Ich sage natürlich, also es sollte sie beeindrucken, weil die sich letzten Endes es mit einer gesamten äh Generation verscherzen ähm.
Und natürlich jetzt haben wir diese interessante Situation, dass die zuständige Ministerin
offen zur Ablehnung von den Upload-Filtern aufgerufen hat, auch an diesem Wochenende wieder
Also ich äh will die Leute nur ermutigen, der jetzt weiter irgendwie der Stachel
im Nacken der der Bundesregierung zu sein, weil also wenn sie dem zustimmen wollen im Rat, dann sollten wir das zumindest so schmerzhaft und schwer für sie machen wie irgend möglich, weil ich glaube, die öffentliche Meinung in Deutschland ist ganz klar dagegen.
Ich bin heute am äh Willy-Brandt-Haus vorbeigegangen. Nur mal gucken
Äh da war ein, da hängt das äh Plakat oder die Werbung von Katharina Barley äh zur Europawahl. Sie ist ja Spitzenkandidatin der SPD ist ähm ein Europa für alle oder
ein Europa für alle.
Da würde das ja zumindest noch reinpassen. Also der Slogan ist ja relativ breit. Da könnte man ja auch äh sie nochmal.
Mitmotivieren, dass äh zu den allen ja wahrscheinlich auch wir und sie dazu gehören.
Absolut, also da muss jetzt äh Katharina Barley nochmal Farbe bekennen.
Problem ist, äh wenn so eine Trilogeinigung schon da ist, dann kommt das nicht unbedingt in den Ministerrat, der dafür fachlich zuständig ist, sondern einfach in den nächsten Rat, der zufällig tra
tagt, also bei äh die Softwarepatente wurden im Fischereiausschuss gestoppt äh oder Fischereirat äh sozusagen
das heißt also wir wissen nicht genau, welcher Minister dann tatsächlich irgendwie am Knopf sitzen wird oder insofern ist es dann auch wichtig, sich jetzt nicht nur auf Katharina Barley einzuschießen. Also natürlich entscheidet
die Bundesregierung am Ende gemeinsam und es ist extrem wichtig, dass die SPD dann ganz klar.
Dem Koalitionsvertrag besteht, der ja dagegen ist, aber das reicht nicht. Also wir müssen schon auch weiter die Union bearbeiten,
ähm weil es könnte eben sein, dass am Ende Bali gar nicht abstimmt.
Aber das bedeutet im Grunde äh kann man sagen, es hängt am Merkel oder ist es einfach nur welcher CDU-CSU-Minister dann auch immer am neunten April im Rat sitzt.
Nee, also ich würde sagen, es ist äh es liegt an Merkel, weil äh ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass jetzt ein einzelner Unionsminister da irgendwie ausscheren würde.
Ja und eine andere Möglichkeit, auf die ich auch nur zu sprechen kommen wollte, ist, man kann das Ding natürlich auch wieder weglagen. Das ist was wir
entschieden haben bei Abicenter Works, so wie bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung auch, aber nachdem du seine Richtlinie ist, ist es extrem
mühsam und funktioniert auch nicht wirklich sauber, weil
man braucht dafür halt Jahre und auch dann können nationale Umsetzungen übrig bleiben von dem Gesetz, weil auch wenn man die Richtlinie aufheben lässt, äh, bleiben die nationalen Gesetze da übrig und
ähm es gibt da verschiedene Wege, wie man klagen kann. Äh der
der am einfachsten für äh NGOs geht, ist man wartet wirklich bis es umgesetzt ist und klagt dann äh sozusagen das individuell Betroffener dagegen. Ähm es gibt vielleicht auch noch Möglichkeiten, dass Staaten.
Probieren oder dass vielleicht sogar das Parlament, das abstrakte Normenprüfung, aber da bin ich mir nicht sicher, aber die, die Optionen muss man sich jetzt halt auch anschauen, weil ich bin mir recht sicher, dass das Gesetz so wie es jetzt da lieg
ähm sowohl gegen die Datenschutzgrundverordnung verstößt wie auch gegen einige der Grundrechte in der EU Grundrechte Chart.
Mhm.
Ja, also dem würde ich zustimmen. Ich glaube, äh also für mich ist tatsächlich Klagen immer die die Option, wenn alles andere nicht mehr geht, weil ähm
letzten Endes haben wir ja bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung gesehen, dass selbst im Erfolgsfall man dann eben immer noch mit den nationalen Gesetzen zu kämpfen hat und das ist ein sehr langer Kampf, also davon könnt ihr sicherlich bei bei Appicenter ein Lied von
von singen. Ich glaube also wenn wir die Annahme im Rat nicht verhindern können, dann ist das wahrscheinlich der sinnvolle nächste Schritt
genauso eben wie zu versuchen bei bei der nationalen Umsetzung irgendwie das Schlimmste zu verhindern. Aber ich glaube zunächst mal muss halt immer noch äh die politische Lösung versucht äh werden zu finden und die ist eben, dass das weiter Druck auf die Regierung gemacht wird, das Ganze abzulehnen.
Da hätte ich ja noch eine praktische Frage. Und zwar ähm die Richtlinie selbst ist ja nicht direkt anwendbar, sondern erst die Umsetzung in nationales Recht. Ähm.
Wenn jetzt Frankreich diese Richtlinien umsetzt, werden die natürlich sich die Hände reiben und das möglichst ähm radikal tun und äh.
Die äh für Rettungsgesellschaften dort wahrscheinlich auch sehr klagsfreudig sind.
Das dann eigentlich auch schon auf äh Plattformen in anderen EU-Ländern Auswirkungen haben ähm beziehungsweise ähm
andere andere Frage, die damit zusammenhängt. Äh wir haben ja Unterschiede in den Ausnahmen für Urheberrecht, sowas wie Panorama, Freiheit äh.
Gibt's da irgendeine Möglichkeit, die du dir mal durchgedacht hast, wie ein Filter auf sowas Rücksicht nehmen kann.
Können die nicht, also es ist sowieso ein Märchen, das Uploadfilter überhaupt auf Urheberrechtsausnahmen berücksichtigen können. Dazu sind sie nicht in der Lage.
Und dementsprechend sind sie natürlich auch nicht in der Lage Unterschiede in nationalen Umsetzungen von Schranken abzubilden. Ähm also um ein einfaches.
Zu nehmen das Zitatrecht.
Sagen manche Leute, also ich hab das auch von der Achse Forst glaub ich schon gehört, ja dann lassen wir einfach drei Sekunden zu oder zehn Sekunden oder was auch immer und danach wird's geblock.
Aber so funktioniert das Zitatrecht ja nicht in der Praxis. Also im deutschen Zitat
kommt es nicht darauf, alles. Also es kommt nicht auf die Länge an, sondern es kommt darauf an, ob man sich kritisch mit dem Inhalt auseinandersetzt und das kann kein äh Upload-Filter erkennen. Ähm
aber um deine Frage zu beantworten, also äh ein Rechtinhaber kann überall dort klagen, wo ein urheberrech
geschützter Inhalt ähm verfügbar ist
dann ist natürlich also nach dem Artikel dreizehn ist die Logik, dass das verfügbar machen nicht nur von dem User.
Ausgeht, sondern auch von der Plattform und ähm.
Wenn also eine Plattform, die ihren Sitz in Deutschland hat, den Inhalt in Frankreich verfügbar macht.
Dann könnte dieser rechte Inhaber wohl auf Grundlage der französischen Umsetzung in Frankreich klagen. Das Problem ist, äh die französischen Gerichte sind gar nicht immer so.
Ähm ja, radikal wie die Regierung und einer der Gründe, weshalb
äh Frankreich überhaupt äh diese ganze Regelung mit den Upload-Filtern so gerne haben will, ist das halt französische Gerichte im Gegensatz zu den Deutschen. In der Vergangenheit immer gesagt haben, also
ist illegal, das äh verstößt gegen äh das Verbot.
Von generellen Überwachungspflichten in der E-Commerce-Richtlinie. Während irgendwie deutsche Gerichte, teilweise Notes and Stay down, in Einzelfällen angeordne
Taten. Und ähm dann stellt sich jetzt die Frage, also auf der einen Seite sagt äh äh die Urheberrechtsrichtlinie.
Dass der Upload verhindert werden muss, auf der anderen Seite sagt er aber auch.
Darf aber keine generelle Überwachungspflicht sein, also es kann sein, dass am Ende sogar rechte Inhaber mit den deutschen Gerichten mehr Erfolg haben als mit dem französischen. Aber das ist wirklich schwer vorauszusehen.
Okay, aber ich finde es schon mal lustig, dass es so ein zwischenzeitliche Lösung sein kann, Frankreich zu blocken, weil Frankreich sich hier in dieser Reform auch besonders negativ hervorgetan hat. Ähm
Eine Sache hast du angesprochen, die ich ganz wichtig für die Zukunft finde und das ist ähm die E-Commerce-Richtlinie.
Inzwischen auch schon klare Statements von der Kommission, dass wir in der nächsten EU-Legislaturperiode eine Reform davon sehen werden und wer das nicht kennt, das ist die Regelung in der das bisherige.
Host Provider Privileg festgeschrieben ist, also die Tatsache, dass man als Plattform eben nicht sofort haftet, wenn irgendein Nutzer etwas Illegales auf der eigenen Plattform.
Dass es dort festgeschrieben.
Daran wurde jetzt schon hier in der Urheberrechtsrichtlinie geruckelt und dieses ganze Prinzip soll reformiert werden. Ähm.
Und da steht jetzt natürlich mit dieser Entscheidung auch sehr viel negatives unserem Haus. Es ist zu befürchten, dass.
Uploadfilter jetzt mal in mittlerer Zukunft schon für die Terrorverordnung sehen, also das ist ein anderes Gesetz, was noch zumindest in erster Lesung vor der EU-Wahl beschlossen werden soll ähm und.
Da äh geht es auch wiederum um Uploadfilter für terroristische Inhalte und,
äh die haben jetzt natürlich Rückenwind mit der Entscheidung droht uns auch hier.
Das Uploadfilter ausgeweitet werden, also wir sehen gerade in, in Lichtgeschwindigkeit
dass ähm ja dieses dieses Prinzip von äh irgendwelche Algorithmen und äh nicht einsehbare äh Filtertechnologien, äh die eben oft auch
noch dazu zentralisiert von einigen wie den Konzernen sind, werden herangezogen, um Meinungsfreiheit zu regulieren. Das ist so ziemlich die Dystopie, die wir uns nur hätten, ausmachen können und die wird jetzt Schritt für Schritt
Realität.
Ja, also das wird der große netzpolitische Konflikt der nächsten Legislatur diese äh geplante Reform der E-Commerce-Richtlinie. Es ist ja bekannt, also dass oftmals bei
matischen, netzpolitischen Entwicklungen, vor allen Dingen Sachen, die mit Überwachung zu tun haben, immer das Urheberrecht vorgeschickt wird und danach werden die Begehrlichkeiten wach für andere Anwendungen.
Und da ist schon also das Host Provider Privileg insgesamt äh in Frage gestellt durch diese Pläne.
Ja, wir haben viel vor. Ach, mein Gott, Julia, ähm wisst ihr nicht, wirklich, wenn man weitermachen, eine Legislaturperiode? Bitte.
Ach, ich glaube, das muss nicht unbedingt sein, ne.
Sag uns wenigstens noch kurz, was du denn jetzt vorhast. Also wenn du uns schon im Stich lässt hier mit dem mit dem mit dem Desaster. Ich würde
wirklich gerne, also du hast es ja ein bisschen durchklingen lassen. Ich kann nur verstehen, dass du da ähm diplomatisch bleibst, aber es ist natürlich ähm für mich als, als.
Beobachter der Politik schon ein ein sehr bezeichnendes ähm.
Oder ein bezeichnender Moment, wenn jetzt eine äh sehr äh
engagierte, kompetente Person ähm in einem in einem in einer Auseinandersetzung landet mit äh weniger ähm kompetenten ähm.
Aber auch irgendwie engagierten Personen und dann wirklich ähm hinwirft. Ich meine, niemand will.
Man will niemandem wünschen, Berufspolitiker zu werden und das äh möchte ich auch dir nicht wünschen, aber es ist natürlich schon schade, dass dass du da gehst. Würdest du sagen, dass das.
In Anführungszeichen System und Umfeld Parlament ähm irgendwie strukturell.
Strukturelle Eigenschaften hat, die verbessert werden müssten, um dort irgendwie rationaler und ja vielleicht.
Basierter wissenschaftlicher ähm.
Mit den Themen umzugehen oder ist das jetzt auch einfach, dass du sagst, okay, ich persönlich habe jetzt keinen Bock drauf, aber man kann ja auch schauen, wenn man jetzt jemand anders nimmt wie Jan Philipp Albrecht, der hat sich da auch äh zwei Legislaturperioden durchgebissen, ist jetzt in einer äh Wagen, glaube ich, zwei, ne?
Ja
Und ist jetzt irgendwie äh weiter in der Politik geblieben ist das jetzt eher eine eine private Entscheidung oder hast du
tatsächlich irgendwie Sachen, wo du sagst, okay, pass auf, das läuft in diesem System falsch. Ich schreibe da ein Buch drüber und dann machen wir die, machen wir eine neue Europäische Union und äh schreiben eine neue Verfassung und dann wird alles besser.
Also ich glaube es ist ein bisschen von beidem. Äh es ist vor allen Dingen erstmal eine private Entscheidung, aber ich glaube, dass ähm.
Wahrscheinlich die strukturellen Probleme, die ich sehe, jetzt nicht speziell fürs Europaparlament sind. Also sicherlich äh der Zugang von Lobbyisten zum Gesetzgebungsprozess.
Katastrophal äh weitgehend. Ich äh gehe davon aus, dass das in der Bundespolitik ganz genauso ist
sind sicherlich strukturelle Sachen, was das Leben als Abgeordnete angeht, ähm die das Ganze für mich persönlich abschreckend machen. Also das hat auch viel mit dieser krassen Privilegierung zu tun.
Geordnete in diesem Systemparlament haben ähm
Es hat teilweise mit der Verwaltung zu tun, dass die Verwaltung ähm selbst Politik macht, auf eine Art und Weise, der ich oft äh nicht zustimme. Ähm.
Ja, also ich denke, es ist hat viele Gründe, aber ich glaube, ich muss das auch erstmal sacken lassen und für mich reflektieren, ob ich da jetzt äh irgendwie äh großartige, grundsätzliche Schlüsse draus äh draus ziehen will. Also ähm.
Ja, schwer zu sagen.
Nein, ich habe noch eine Frage Julia und zwar ähm wir haben jetzt ja doch ähm vielleicht waren's zweieinhalb Jahre Kampagne gehabt und äh
wem haben wir da aller zu danken? Also wer ist da involviert gewesen? Ähm wer weil das hat sich ja alles immer sehr stark auf dich fokussiert und ich glaube niemand hat so intensiv und stark an dem Thema gearbeitet, wie du aber wo sollen die Leute
hinschauen, wenn sie Antworten suchen, wenn du vielleicht ähm.
Äh uns nicht mehr so so stark zur Verfügung stehst, wie das die letzten Jahre der Fall war.
Ja unglaublich viele Leute, also ich glaub was bei dieser Reform sehr gut gelaufen ist, dass sich zum Beispiel die wissenschaftliche Community von Anfang an sehr lautstark zu Wort gemeldet hat und immer klar gesagt hat, also was an diesen Vorschlägen nicht
geht, ähm sicherlich äh Edri hat extrem äh viel gemacht, auch wenn
Urheberrecht jetzt nicht ihr alleroberstes Thema ist, also meistens äh äh standen da ja
in der Vergangenheit ähm so Genuine Datenschutzthemen im Vordergrund. Trotzdem hat sich Edri entschieden, dass das ein super wichtiges Thema für sie ist und natürlich auch die diversen Mitgliederorganisationen
ich denke irgendwie, dass hier im Parlament.
Im Hintergrund unglaublich viele Leute äh da dran arbeiten, auch jetzt in den letzten Tagen noch Stimmen gesammelt haben im Hintergrund versuchen, Leute zu überzeugen und ganz oft sind das auch irgendwie die Jüngeren
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern von relativ ähm alten äh Semestern im Parlament. Also äh wir wissen ja irgendwie die, das Durchschnittsalter bei den
geordneten ist Mitte fünfzig, ist aber immer wieder mal vorgekommen, dass auch äh Assistentinnen, Assistenten von EVP Abgeordneten zu mir gekommen sind und mir erzählt haben, hey
Jugendlichen, der da anrufen, die kennen sich voll gut aus und ich benutze diese Plattform auch und äh mache mir Sorgen um das freie Internet und so weiter. Und teilweise haben natürlich diese Leute auch
äh Überzeugungsarbeit geleistet, weil halt die Abgeordneten auch auf äh
ihre Teams hören und auf die Leute, denen sie vertrauen. Und also wenn man sich jetzt die deutschen Abgeordneten speziell anguckt, äh muss ich auch nochmal besonders äh Timo Wölken hervorheben. Der ist spät ins Parlament nach.
Glaube zweitausendsechzehn oder so und hatte die zweifelhafte Ehre quasi mehr oder weniger durch Zufall.
Ein Urheberrechts äh Dossier zu übernehmen. Das war nämlich der Versuch, äh das Geoblocking abzuschaffen. Und da ist er halt als junger Abgeordneter einfach so rangegangen, hat gesagt.
Geoblocking fanden wir schon immer alles Scheiße und hat dazu einen ziemlich vernünftigen Vorschlag gemacht und.
Eine Art und Weise von der Filmindustrie äh angegriffen worden davon. Ähm also bis hin zu Artikeln in der FAZ,
die EU will die Filmwirtschaft abschaffen und so weiter und ich glaube das hat ihn auch so ein bisschen für das Thema radikalisiert und ich glaube unterm Strich.
Hat da wahrscheinlich die rechte Verwerterindustrie einen großen strategischen Fehler gemacht, weil der ist sicherlich jemand, der an dem Thema dranbleiben will und sich auch
äh von diesen Lobbys nicht mehr einlullen lässt. Äh das war jetzt irgendwie eine eine.
Auswahl, es gibt sicher super viel andere, die es wert ist zu erwähnen, alle die irgendwie auf die Demos gehen
oder welche organisieren die über das Thema Schreiben, Videos machen und so weiter sind alle extrem wichtig und selbst, also manche.
Unabhängigen Instanzen, die sich einfach mit ihrer Expertise da einbringen, also der Bundesdatenschutzbeauf.
Der UN-Sonderberichterstatter und so weiter ähm sind auch alle super wichtig, um da irgendwie äh zu sehen, dass diese diese Kritik äh wirklich fundiert ist.
Eine letzte Frage habe ich noch, weil du das jetzt auch nochmal angesprochen hast. Das Urheberrechtsthema ist ja gerade in Europa nicht
erste Netzpolitische Thema ähm was was oft in den NGOs verankert ist. Also wir haben mehr NGOs, die sich eher mit Privatsphäre und Datenschutz beschäftigen, als jetzt mit Nehzentralität oder Urheberrecht oder Fragen der Plattformregulierung generell.
Und gleichzeitig haben wir eine extrem Angriffe Urheberrechtslobby. Also äh von.
Telekom-Industrie bin ich bei weitem nicht solche Ar.
Gewohnt, auch wenn man sich mit Innenministern oder Innenministerin auseinandersetzt bei Überwachungsgesetzen komme da nicht so
harte und Untergriffe gegen Attacken, wieso ist das beim Urheberrecht so verkoxt? Also du hast das ja jetzt äh brilliant, fünf Jahre lang
ausgehalten und dir wahrscheinlich auch sehr viel anhören müssen über
deine Person, deine Arbeit und die Fakten, die du verträgst, ähm
Wieso ist das Orberechtsthema in der Hinsicht so radikal anders aus anderen als politischen Themen.
Das hat einen ganz einfachen Grund, weil die Unterhaltungsindustrie Einfluss über die öffentliche Meinung hat
und auch bereit ist, diesen Einfluss zu nutzen. Und das weiß die Politik natürlich. Und über Jahre, wenn nicht Jahrzehnte war es äh diese Lobby gewöhnt, alles zu bekommen, was sie von der Politik fordert
erst mit dem Aufkommen des Internets, mit Acta wahrscheinlich ähm
gab es zum ersten Mal in irgendeiner Form eine Gegenbewegung dagegen und das sind die nicht gewohnt und äh in dementsprechend äh gehen sie eben auch vor, also mit einer Selbstverständlichkeit, dass jeder Politiker, den ich zu hundert Prozent das vertritt, was sie für richtig halten, äh massiv persönlich angegriffen wird.
So, ich will jetzt aber nicht unhöflich sein. Ich habe in sechs Minuten eine Verabredung zum Abendessen.
Julia, wir sind dir so dankbar, dass du dir überhaupt diese Zeit genommen hast an diesem doch sehr wichtigen und ereignisreichen Tag. Wir wissen es wirklich sehr zu schä
zen,
Bitte, bitte, bitte, tu mir nur einen Gefallen, sag noch bitte, wer die Leute in deinem Team sind, damit wir die auch noch im auf dem Schirm halten können für zukünftige Karrieren in, in der Gutmenschenindustrie.
Okay, also ich weiß gar nicht, ob die jetzt alle genannt werden möchten. Ich gucke mal, möchtet ihr, dass ich äh eure Namen nenne? Äh.
Ja, okay, also äh hier in Straßburg mit mir sitzen jetzt irgendwie Christopher Klay, der macht meine Kommunikation
Marlene Straub, die
macht in Berlin Kommunikation, Community und Policy, Estabako, die für die Urheberrechtsreform auf der Policy Seite zuständig war.
Rausgerannt ist gerade der Sebastian Reible, der macht äh andere Themen wie Cyber-Security und Open Data
in Brüssel unterstützt mich noch äh Justus, der auch äh Verwaltung und Community macht. Justus Römert. Äh ich hoffe, ich habe jetzt niemanden vergessen.
Ähm ist doch ein größeres Team.
Julia, vielen herzlichen Dank an dich und dein Team für alle Arbeit, allen Einsatz und ähm lasst es euch schmecken und danke, dass du dir die Zeit genommen hast und viel Erfolg auf deinen zukünftigen Wegen
und danke für viele Jahre Politik, so wie man's gerne haben möchte.
Ja, danke euch. Macht's gut. Ciao.
Und bevor wir wieder eine etwas ausfasernde Sendung wie beim letzten Mal machen, belassen wir es jetzt hierbei. Ich ähm kann nur nochmal wirklich meine.
Wirklich meine Freude darüber zum Ausdruck bringen, dass äh Julia sich heute für uns Zeit genommen hat. Ähm sehr kurzfristig und ähm ja, die Kritik zur letzten Sendung ist angekommen. Wir haben uns da ein bisschen.
Verzählt, die hätte auch in die Hälfte der Zeit gepasst, aber so ist das eben manchmal, wenn man.
Bisschen wenig schläft, ein bisschen viel um die Ohren hat und sich dann doch noch wenigstens die Mühe geben möchte einen Podcast.
Zu kredenzen.
Insofern hoffe ich, ihr bleibt uns auch weiterhin für äh schlechte Nachrichten auch direkt auf die Ohren gewogen und ich habe keine Ahnung.
Wird diese Sendung betiteln werden, aber als Outro war ja offenbar.
Ihr alle gar nicht mehr Athletinate, Riot kennt und solange wir bei der Meta-Ebene noch keinen Upload-Filter haben.
Würde ich sagen, gibt's jetzt ein bisschen schöne Musik. Ciao, ciao.